[موسيقى]
أجنبية
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
كان عالِمًا عظيمًا لديه
شغف بالحقيقة
ولكن  لم يكن من العدل حقًا أنه لم يكن
فقط
ذكيًا وماهرًا بشكل لا يصدق
يدويًا ، كل الهدايا التي تحتاجها لتكون
عالِمًا رائعًا ، لقد كان أيضًا
وسيمًا بشكل غير عادي ، أعني أنه
كان وسيمًا جدًا حقًا كان لديه
زوجة جميلة أطفال ساحرون
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شكرًا لك على
ما كان عليه العمل مع بيتر ،
فمن دواعي سروري الشديد أنه كان
محاطًا بزملائه الذين استمتعوا
بأفكاره وشخصيته المستعدين
للعمل بجد كما فعل على الرغم من
أنه كان مديرًا لـ  المعهد كان
لا يزال يقضي يومين ونصف اليوم كاملاً في
تدريس مادة العلوم أسبوعيًا وكان
مهتمًا بالكثير من الأشياء بخلاف
العلوم
[الموسيقى]
الأجنبية